los materiales elecciones y un polémico
referendo cerca de 13 millones de
Ecuatorianos elegirán
5.660 autoridades locales las campañas
culminaron el 2 de febrero el
oficialismo trató de desmarcarse el
presidente Guillermo lasso quien ha
visto su popularidad afectada por
escándalos recientes de corrupción en su
familia
el debate no se centró en los candidatos
sino en ocho reformas constitucionales
que lazos somete referendo y que la
oposición ha señalado que representan un
riesgo para la democracia la reforma
constitucional Busca reducir el número
de asambleístas controlar el número de
afiliados a los movimientos políticos a
través del Consejo Nacional electoral y
aumentar la autonomía de la fiscalía
general la designación del fiscal
pasaría a manos de la asamblea nacional
esta también seleccionaría a los
miembros del Consejo de participación
ciudadana organismo de control creado en
2008 que elige al procurador general
otra enmienda Busca la extradición
quienes hayan cometido delitos
relacionados con el crimen organizado
transnacional como el narcotráfico
tráfico de armas y la trata de personas
desde la oposición la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas compuesta por
14 pueblos originarios anunció que no
apoyara ninguna reforma el 18 de
noviembre la conaie decidió trabajar en
la consulta popular todo por el no el
gobierno se mantiene firme y defiende
como uno de los ejes de sus propuestas
la lucha contra el crimen organizado
creo que además manda un mensaje
comunicacional importante y que los
Ecuatorianos estamos dispuestos a
decirle sí a un ecuador más seguro menos
politiquería y también más cuidadoso con
el medio ambiente los Ecuatorianos
también votarán sobre la creación de un
subsistema de protección
hídrica al Sistema Nacional de áreas
protegidas y compensaciones para los
ciudadanos que cuiden el ambiente